2 perte immense pour le cinéma à
quelques heures d'intervalle que le
brenner et orson welles viennent de
mourir
renault la grève ne s'étant pas comme le
voudrait la cgt une épreuve de vérité
pour la centrale syndicale plus de
subventions pour le beurre européen à
cette année il n'y aura pas de peur de
noël les occidentaux demandent un
jugement sévère pour le commande ou de
là qu'il est là oro qui a tué un des
passagers du paquebot
mesdames messieurs bonsoir c'est une
journée affreusement noir pour le cinéma
américain est bien au delà pour le
cinéma tout court puisque elle a
commencé avec ce matin l'annnonce de la
mort de gueule brenner et qu'elle se
termine avec celle de la disparition
d'orson welles un autre deuil
considérable
orson welles vient de s'étendre vient de
s'éteindre à hollywood il avait 70 ans
il ya à peine un mois il avait signé sa
dernière oeuvre c'est est un disque dont
nous allons entendre quelques phrases
qui ce soir constitue vraiment une sorte
de testament
il
tout bio
henry chapier on est un peu à court de
superlatifs pour qualifier orson welles
parce que d'une part il laisse une
oeuvre considérable et puis il ya aussi
créé un grand nombre d'événements depuis
plus de 40 ans oui il faudrait peut-être
commencer par le début dire en moins
qu'il avait fait cette émission de radio
phénoménal qui a fait courir tout new
york dans la rue parce qu'il a fait
croire à l'arrivée des martiens
après bien sûr il faudrait retenir au
moins les trois signes que le public
connaît le plus citizen kane par exemple
la soif du mal et othello mais bien
entendu on ne peut pas résumer sa
carrière ce soir ni sa polyvalence
mais ce qui faut dire à tout prix c'est
que ce créateur extraordinaire camille
l'imagination au pouvoir et qui a
vraiment créé cette magie du cinéma
eh bien il a fait contre les producteurs
contre le système au lieu d'un contre
l'industrie et ça c'est extraordinaire
parce que quand même il est resté
peut-être quinze ans à ne faire que
trois signes trois grands films mais il
n'a jamais cédé
et c'est un exemple extraordinaire comme
éditera longtemps ils en parlaient ya un
an seulement à paris aux jeunes veulent
elles de lydec
voilà ce qu'on peut dire du personnage
mais évidemment n'a pas le temps de
parler de soleure oui parce qu'il faut
également dire quelques mots de yul
brynner je disais que la journée était
noire aujourd'hui ils brûlèrent et est
mort d'un cancer on l'a appris ce matin
alors là c'était un immense comédien est
à la fois un comédien de cinéma et de
théâtre
c'était aussi un homme tout à fait
étrange je ne savais pas du tout où
était né d'où il venait
il y avait toute une mythologie du
personnage qu'il a créé et qui l'a
forget qui l'a encouragé ville a eu
aussi le secret il faut bien le dire
alors yul brynner on retiendra bien
entendu les sept samouraïs de kurzawa
car il a tourné avec eux au savoir on se
souvient évidemment également des fêtes
mercenaires avec johnston
on se souvient de ce crâne rasé
emblématique qui l'a fait entrer dans la
légende
mais alors où il y est entré lui avec
une comédie musicale qui a tenu
l'affiché pendant 25 ans à new york et
le souvenir de ces images le voit si
c'était de king nda et le roi et moi
revenons à l'actualité française
maintenant avec la grève grève avec
occupation lancé à l'usiné renault du
mans par la cgt et la cfdt une grève qui
ne fait pas tâche d'huile dans les
autres usines du groupe et de ce fait
cet événement prend des allures de test
pour la cgt avant d'en examiner les
conséquences sociales et politiques
voyons en détail la situation chez
renault en commençant par flins
généralement très combative flins où
cette fois ci la grève ne semble pas
prendre
claude guaino à flins la mayonnaise n'a
pas pris ce matin l'appel à un arrêt de
travail lancé par la cgt la cfdt n'a été
observée que par 22 grévistes sur 7000
salariés indique la direction
quant au meeting il n'a rassemblé que 2
100 personnes pas plus de succès cet
après midi dans l'ensemble les renault
de flins ne se sentait que peu concernés
pour moi c'est le métrage prochain et la
grèce qui sans en passer
politique les gens moins de patience on
pend sont pas bien rapproché mais ça ça
vous décide pas faire la grève pour le
moment dit oui à tanger il y a en fait
de nombreux sujets de mécontentement à
la régie renault est un très profond
malaise mais simplement la plupart des
travailleurs s'interroge sur le fait est
ce qu'on peut vraiment gagner dans une
période telle que celle là
les travailleurs immigrés de flins
disent de manière très claire de toute
façon nous maintenant nous ne bougerons
fossiles de manière significative le
travailleur français du jaune d'oeuf la
bouche un clairon la grève n'a pas vu
plus de succès 200 personnes seulement
sur 4000 ont débrayé ce matin commis
hier beaucoup plus cependant dit la cgt
nous avons une participation au meeting
relativement moyenne nous devons le dire
mais les rassemblements dans les
ateliers sont beaucoup plus importants
alors il faut lui il faut joindre les
deux quoi dans les autres usines à
sandouville et à douai la situation
était considéré comme normal
il est à noter qu à flins et a dès
demain et lundi il y aura du chômage
technique
un handicap pour la cgt la cfdt qui ne
pourront pas mobilisé les salariés
restés à la maison à
boulogne-billancourt en revanche l'usiné
occupée et les chaînes paralysé
la cgt a lancé toutes ses forces dans la
bataille mais ce n'est pas sans friction
avec la cfdt
pour la cfdt le vote de la grève s'est
déroulée dans des conditions déplorables
la cgt a imposé l'occupation c'est ce
que la direction de la régie va tenter
de montrer au mans en revanche le
mouvement est bien enracinée et le
mécontentement sur les salaires profond
la grève a été votée par une large
majorité par plus de 200 salariés même
si la cgt n'arrive pas à étendre le
conflit la régie renault au mans est
confronté un réel problème
oui l'attitude de la cgt dans ce conflit
et dans d'autres qui l'ont précédé vient
d'être condamné d'une manière très vive
et très ferme par edmond maire le
secrétaire général de la cfdt vient de
donner une interview à fr3 orléans où il
n'a pas mâché ses mots
j'étais ces derniers jours est en train
de multiplier maintenant des actions non
seulement de commando on a vu mais aussi
de provocation et d'agressions vers vis
des militants de la cfdt par exemple aux
administrateurs à l'assurance chômage
c'est une sorte de politique du pillar
la cgt semble souhaiter la faillite de
l'assurance sont minces gambie pour les
chômeurs quand il ya des mouvements chez
renault ou une un mécontentement chez
renault ailleurs sur des motifs
légitimes elles tentent de forcer les
formes d'actions y compris en faussant
les consultations et puis surtout à
utiliser le mécontentement pour dénoncer
à des fins politiques tout le monde car
le gouvernement socialiste la droite les
autres confédérations syndicales
finalement c'est une action au service
des intérêts électoraux du parti
communiste à peu près uniquement ce
n'est plus du syndicalisme la cgt ne
fait pas que syndicalisme en ce moment
elle lui elle ternit l'image du
syndicalisme
de son côté henri krasucki appel ce soir
ses adhérents à agir fort
et en grand dit il pour répondre à ce
qu'il appelle un grave recul industriel
organisé la cgt se mobilisent en
particulier en prévision de sa journée
d'action prévue pour le 24 octobre est
en fait cette mobilisation a sans doute
commencé depuis le début de cet été
comme nous le rappelle marc cartierre
tout au long de l'été elle va organiser
des coups d'éclat c'est un symbole
l'usiné skf avait été avec ça c'est la
cgt qui avait été expulsé son souci
enrayer la perte de son audience en
défendant l'emploi
c'est le coup de poing à
trith-saint-léger pour éviter le
transfert des activités au luxembourg ne
pas laisser un seul conflit sans tapage
provoquer les opérations spectacle dont
on parle est chauffé le climat c'est
ainsi que la cgt piste à travers la
france le train qui emporte les machines
outils de l'usiné renault de douai pour
les transférer en espagne il faut qu'on
puisse dire d'elle voilà une
organisation qui nous défend et ne se
contente pas de discours et de
programmes
bref la cgt veut donner d'elle une image
combative
sans hésiter à provoquer des
perturbations forçant l'attention de
tous ceux qui fut le cas lors de ces
actions de commandos la cgt bloquent la
circulation en plein champs elysées avec
des voitures renault dont elle dénonce
la fabrication à l'étranger en quelque
sorte la centrale durci son action pour
prouver qu elle au moins ne se laissera
pas berner par l'austérité et cela au
risque de perdre définitivement l'image
du grand syndicat responsable
oui vous pardonnerai j'ai l'impression
que nous avons un problème de son pour
écouter la ligne thériault qui marie
quartier nous propose est peut-être en
train de tout à l'heure en tout cas une
autre analyse qu'on peut faire de ces
conflits et politique cela elle consiste
à s'interroger comme le faisait
l'instant edmond maire sur le rôle du
parti communiste dont beaucoup pensent
que par l'intermédiaire de la cgt ils
cherchent à appuyer son offensive contre
le gouvernement
fernand tavarès examine maintenant cette
hypothèse le comité central du pcf 2 mai
dernier avait été marqué par la volonté
des dirigeants communistes de critiquer
plus fortement le gouvernement et le ps
la cgt s'était même vu reprocher son
manque de combativité ce qui avait
provoqué de la part d'henri krasucki une
réaction du style la cgt ça n'est pas le
pcf
elle est indépendante des partis une
réflexion qui n'a pas été du goût de
tout le monde
à tel point que l'opération skf dans
laquelle sont intervenus ont cédé
municipalités communistes auraient été
montés dit on du moins dans sa phase
principale sans l'aval du secrétaire
général de la cgt une cgt musclé et des
militants communistes étroitement
associés les retrouvera plus tard à alès
devant la mairie ils attendent en soi
mitterrand en voyage en languedoc
roussillon casse des panneaux à son
effigie et fait nouveau on fait même le
coup de poing avec les socialistes
locaux venus applaudir le chef de l'état
partout où le président se déplace pas
en france il trouvera une cgt en colère
soutenue par le pcf
but de l'opération condamner
publiquement la politique de celui
qu'ils ont contribué à porter au pouvoir
en 81 alors yat-il connivence objective
entre la cgt et le pcr lorsqu'une
journaliste pose la question à françois
mitterrand y répond malicieusement il me
semble qu'ils disent la même chose
reste à observer ce qui va se passer au
prochain bureau confédéral
certains pronostiquent enfonce un devis
affrontements ps pcf
mais de là à supposer qu une tendance
plus forte puisse expulser l'autre il y
a de la marge
car c'est peut-être de la survie d'un
des plus grands syndicats français dont
il est question
l'autre événement politique très
important de cette semaine c'est le
congrès du parti socialiste qui va
s'ouvrir demain à toulouse un congrès
capital qui prépare législatives
un congrès qui également devra trancher
de nombreux débats internes à la veille
de son ouverture cela dit l'ambiance
toulouse est plutôt bon enfant nicole
zimmermann exit le salon du temps libre
place au congrès vendredi ils seront
cinq mille assister au congrès national
du parti socialiste à toulouse
pour l'instant le parc des expositions
se met aux couleurs de la région et
installe les lieux un hall pour
l'accueil des congressistes et les
accréditations un hall pour les
différents stands d'information et un
rôle pour le congrès proprement dit une
salle où auront accès les délégués
représentant les fédérations les
auditeurs et les personnalités invitées
plus de 120 pays seront représentés
quant à la restauration
elle occupe carrément de halls du parc
des expositions
le restaurant fournira trois mille cinq
cents repas tous les midis 12000
assiette 7000 litres de vins de fronton
occupe déjà les lieux on attend pour
demain les 400 kilos de haricots
nécessaire à l'inévitable cassoulet de
vendredi la fédération socialiste de la
haute garonne a mobilisé plus de 400
militants tant pour l'accueil que pour
le service d'ordre est prévu une
animation culturelle vendredi soir les
autres soirs sami congressistes seguer
rond dans la ville bonne opération pour
les restaurants et pour toulouse en
général on estime en effet à 2 milliards
l'apport de ce congrès à toulouse
avec à la clé une réputation de ville de
congrès à asseoir plus de 500
journalistes couvriront en effet
l'événement le coup d'envoi de la
campagne pour les législatives de 86
pour l'instant rocardien et
mitterrandiste cloud scotch et
transporte avec la même ardeur
reste à voir comment on tournera le vent
de 2 à 4 ans de prison avec sursis pour
les quatre militants corses du flnc qui
avait fabriqué de faux dollars pour
alimenter les caisses de leur mouvement
le jugement vient d'être rendu par la
cour d'assises de paris
les agriculteurs victimes de la
sécheresse se jugent toujours
insuffisante l'indemnisation que leur
propose le ministre henri nallet à rodez
la nuit dernière 400 éleveurs ont tiré
les habitants de leur sommeil en tapant
sur des bidons de lait à 4 heures du
matin au ministère de l'agriculture on
dit rester ouvert au dialogue mais on
n'exclut toujours le principe d'une aide
forfaitaire comme le réclament les deux
principaux syndicats d'agriculteurs et
puis il n'y aura pas de beurre de noël
cette année dans les rayons des
épiceries et des supermarchés c'est la
conséquence la plus tangible d'une
décision que viennent de prendre les
responsables agricoles de l'europe
les excédents ne seront plus
subventionner cette année jean-marie
veulent à la politique agricole commune
est malade de ses stocks pour le beurre
le million de tonnes et dépasser cela
fait 4 milliards de plaquettes huit mois
de consommation
si les stocks coûte cher environ 280 par
kilo le déstockage coûte encore plus
cher et n'est donc plus rentable d'où la
suppression de l' opération beurre de
noël nous avons examiné les résultats de
notre action de l'année passée nous
devons trouver que de toute la quantité
de beurre de yack unis sera mis sur le
marché à un prix réduit
finalement il y avait une consommation
additionnelle de
pour cent ça veut dire que l' écoute
marginaux ravir les couteaux 5%
cent cinq fois le prix qui nous avons
donné pour la lauter la quantité totale
s'achète c'est absurde on peut passer à
côté c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
avons dû décider de ne pas entamer une
action dana autre mesure positive celle
là la mise sur le marché dès la
mi-novembre du vieux beurre en fait du
beurre concentré de cuisine destinés à
l'industrie à la pâtisserie même
artisanale et aux consommateurs donc au
grand public
son prix sera comparable à celui des
margarines plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de tonnes devraient ainsi
disparaître des stocks
françois mitterrand en visite à berlin
ouest le président de la république
réaffirmé ainsi la présence française
dans l'ancienne capitale allemande placé
depuis la fin de la guerre sous la
tutelle des quatre vainqueurs du nazisme
à cause de sa coupure et du fameux mur
berlin est aussi un baromètre des
relations est ouest et c'est également
comme nous l'expliquent gilles du
jonchay un bon indicateur sur l'état des
relations franco allemandes
quand l'avion présidentiel a atterri ce
matin l'aéroport de ta gueule en secteur
français le chancelier ouest allemand
helmut khol étaient à bord ce qui a
obligé français et allemands de l'ouest
à une certaine gymnastique protocolaire
officiellement berlin ouest n'appartient
pas l'allemagne fédérale usage veut donc
aucun membre du gouvernement ouest
allemand ne puisse y accompagner un
dirigeant étranger
pas plus qu'ils ne seraient l'accueillir
à l'aéroport cet usage valéry giscard
d'estaing avait scrupuleusement respecté
il ya six ans les chances et les schmidt
avait dû se rendre à berlin par ses
propres moyens
bien sûr le chancelier kohl s'est
éclipsé à sa descente d'avion
néanmoins le geste du président
mitterrand a été interprétée en rfa
comme une compensation aux voyages
officiels qui avait fait le premier
ministre laurent fabius à berlin en juin
dernier
cette visite avait été marquée par la
présence à table en grand uniforme du
chef de l'armée est allemande en
violation des accords qui font de
l'ancienne capitale du reich une zone
strictement interdite à toute armée
allemande quelle qu'elle soit pour le
reste la journée du président français à
berlin ouest a sacrifié à la tradition
avec notamment le dépôt de gerbes aux
victimes du mur de la honte en présence
du chancelier
comme son prédécesseur à l'elysée
françois mitterrand n'est pas monté sur
l'estrade disposé à côté pour jeter un
regard au delà
dumur télévision la haute autorité de
l'audiovisuel a procédé aujourd'hui au
renouvellement des présidents des trois
chênes pour ce qui concerne fr3 au terme
de son mandat de trois ans le président
hollow transmet ses pouvoirs à madame
janine langlois glandier conseiller
d'état membre de plusieurs cabinets
ministériels
monsieur o lo avait notamment présidé le
centre national du cinéma ainsi que la
commission des radios locales privées
avant son arrivée à fr3 c'est un grand
commis de l'état qui quittent notre
société il sera donc remplacé à partir
du 21 octobre par madame ne glandent
madame langlois glandier je vous le
disais elle à 46 ans elle est directeur
général de la société française de
production c'est une ancienne élève de
l'école nationale de commerce diplômé de
l'institut d'études politiques madame
langlois glandier était entré à la
société française de production en 1975
notons par ailleurs que à tf1 monsieur
hervé bourges a été reconduit dans ses
fonctions et à antenne 2 monsieur jean
drucker qui est actuellement vice
président et directeur général de rtl
succédera à jean-claude eberlé le
colonel kadhafi en visite officielle à
moscou le chef de la révolution libyenne
est arrivé aujourd'hui dans la capitale
soviétique
il a été accueilli par le chef de l'état
andreï gromyko et par le nouveau chef de
la diplomatie soviétique et loire créé
la renaudié c'est la première visite
officielle du colonel kadhafi en urss
depuis un peu plus de quatre ans après
la reddition du commando qui avait
détourné le paquebot achillée lareau
l'italie a demandé officiellement
aujourd'hui l'extradition des quatre
pirates qui semble-t-il sont toujours
détenus en egypte
les etats unis quant à eux demandent un
jugement exemplaire et en particulier à
cause de l'assassinât d'un des passagers
un citoyen américain de religion juive
qui a été jetée à la mer un acte
d'autant plus horrible que cet homme de
69 ans et est hémiplégique
joël hasard
leylaz oro voici l'image la plus
frappante cet américain effondré c'est
la femme de léon klinghoffer le passager
juif exécutés par les pirates
palestiniens l'assassinât de cet homme
invalide à 28/100 froid selon les
témoignages risque d'éclabousser
certains protagonistes de la fesse
l'egypte d'abord qui en toute bonne foi
s'était engagé auprès des pirates a fait
remettre leur départ s'il l'est c'est la
vie sauve aux passagers une promesse qui
pourrait expliquer les contradictions
autour de la destination du commando
pour le président moubarak
les pirates ont quitté son pays mais de
source américaine proche du président
reagan
les pirates seraient toujours en egypte
prêt à s'envoler vers une destination
inconnue
qui faut-il croire faut-il croire aussi
cette affirmation du président moubarak
le commando appartient le lp une
précision qui met à nouveau et yasser
arafat dans une situation compromettante
le chef de l'olp et a condamné fermement
le détournement reste que cette prise
d'otage pourrait être le résultat d'un
dérapage une action concertée au départ
entre les services d'arafat et
l'organisation qui revendique le coup
une action qui aurait dû viser un
objectif militaire en israël et se
serait transformé en détournement de
civils à moins que ce soit précisément
ce que les ennemis d'arafat et voulu
faire croire à la bourse de paris une
hausse très légère aujourd'hui sur les
valeurs françaises est également une
remontée assez sensible du dollar martin
thiébaut le dollar remonte doucement
mais sûrement visiblement le marché des
changes ou à cache cache avec les
banques centrales qui pour l'instant ont
cessé leurs interventions
il est vrai qu'aujourd'hui la plus
vigilante d'entre elles la banque du
japon étaient fermés la bourse de paris
a connu aujourd'hui encore une légère
amélioration
correction des excès de la semaine
passée mais l'ambiance n'est toujours
pas à l'optimisme dans un marché très
nerveux ou les baisses sont en vedette
wall street
l'indécision le dispute à la certitude
c'est encore le problème du déficit
budgétaire et des taux d'intérêt qui
agite les investisseurs
par ailleurs le marché manque toujours
cruellement d'argent et il s'enferre
dans les eaux pea
puis le monde des affaires c'est aussi
rendre hommage aux plus talentueux de
ses membres une jeune femme de 30 ans
catherine painvin vienne vient d'être
désignée femme de l'année femme
d'affaires de l'année par le jury veuve
clicquot la société qu'elle a créé et
qui est un joli nom tartine et chocolat
sa brique qui diffusent de la layette et
des accessoires de puériculture le temps
demain pour terminer il y aura un peu de
brouillard et quelques nuages d'altitude
le matin mais ce ne sera pas bien grave
car dès l'après midi le soleil brillera
de nouveau sur tout le pays
en conséquence les températures
remonteront un peu et elles seront
légèrement supérieures aux normales
saisonnières de m'asseoir je vous
rappelle de rendez-vous la première
édition à 19 heures avec richard tripots
et puis je vous retrouverai pour
l'édition de la soirée à 22h35
la soirée se poursuit maintenant avec le
nouveau magazine millésime mais avant
cela je vous rappelle comme d'habitude
les principales nouvelles de la journée
bonsoir ya demain
les nerfs sont morts à quelques heures
d'intervalle renoue la grève ne s'étant
pas comme le voudrait la cgt c'est une
épreuve de vérité pour la centrale
syndicale
ah qu'il est là au rôle et quatre
membres du commando qui ont tué un
passager du paquebot serait toujours en
egypte
demain ouverture à toulouse du congrès
du parti socialiste